hey guys how's it going so I've got a
little announcement for you I am now a
puppy mommy this is Matt we're calling
him Maddie right now because he's a
little baby so I partnered with creators
for good in the Ad Council to bring
awareness to adopting from shelters and
in my first kickoff call with them and
talking about the projects that I can do
the one thing that I said is you know
this would be really great you know I
wish that I could have a dog but there's
just no way I travel too much I'm so
busy this and that and you know as I was
searching through the website that we
were talking about it I saw this little
guy and his little brothers and his
little sisters and I about lost my mind
two seconds after I got off that phone
call I went and called the shelter and
she's like yeah we have we have five of
them left and that was three weeks ago
and then two weeks ago I emailed and she
said oh we have three left and then a
week ago I called again and she said you
only have one left until yesterday I
went with my sister and my friend Matt
and we went to just take a peek in and
see if he was still there and I said if
he's still there then it's meant to be
and I'm going to take him home and I
will figure out a way to make this work
so this is kind of a really big day I
have been wanting a puppy
so was my sister and we've decided that
I think they know Mike might be the time
I finally convinced her this all kind of
really happens it started looking on the
shelter pet project org and I found well
so many cute little puppies and they
need homes because so many dogs put
shelters than a dog
we don't make it out
and they need homes i iced tea do you
want to come home with me tell me yes or
no my gosh
Matt look they're gonna be such good
friends
wait where's where's not at yes Maddy
we're going together we're going to name
it Matt hang on Maddy Maddy ma TTI you
not to you and matey's ey Maddy's going
to get a mohawk
Oh
I'm hoping some hate tuna not so sneaky
you can deal and you're gonna be
traveling with me that's right gonna be
a man about town all right here we are
I adopted him he needed a home and I was
here for you he's so cute
he'll wake up one day don't we thanks
Wilders I'm so happy he's got a new home
now here's the worst there's actual
matter right in there now
hi little Maddy Maddy little Maddy's
first car ride yes you go on yes of
course
Maddy does not but I do have the feet
fell off socks the mom I've long Zach I
also have a seatbelt
he's probably too little for that now
okay man guys Maddy just made a boo-boo
a minute odds thanks
what smells like goat's milk
and Haley was squirrel oh hi okay okay
I'm get back on hey quit should we get
all of this stuff out yeah
baby's first yeah he's your life to get
back this is like spa day who looks like
a little rat get your computer but ready
but he's a lots of tubes today no or get
actually animals in the water okay I'm
just figuring this all out so you doing
here alone
not about myself so I named a Matt after
a friend Matt I kind of was joking that
I was going to name my dog after him and
we saw we just started calling him Matt
instantly and it stuck here we are this
is Maddie you guys gonna leave me some
puppy training tips leave them in the
comments below and if you or a friend or
anybody is considering getting a pet
please please please consider adoption
because there's so many of these little
guys and girls that can just benefit
from having a nice home like you thank
you guys so much for watching I look
forward to sharing more adventures of me
and Maddie or Maddie and I with you
precious check out the shelter pet
project or agree you guys can search
from your location and you can find
yourself a little Maddy I'm here right
here mmm
we're still working on it